[Musique]
c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvé
invité à cette soirée en haut de la tour
eiffel excuse moi je reviens
merde merde y'a d'la que l es gens n'y a
pas quelqu'un dans le coin corps des
toilettes six mois tu as une soirée à
trois roues de combat l'ambiance est pas
top mais pas ça qui nous intéresse ici
en fait l'ac tomber désolé
mais c'est pas vrai et pas quelqu'un
d'autre
salut j'ai les toilettes mais je suis au
moins 15 minutes
tu peux venir
ok je prends
[Musique]
voici jacquard diop et dès que je peux
courir à la place si tu vas
[Musique]
le
aqua gym à boycotter ces rires non mais
chantôme alimentation
[Musique]
fatma j'allais tout ça
tu prière mais c'est dans ces moments
perdus sur pape c'est mon corps tu fais
quoi là je suis désolé je peux pas
continuer comme ça c'est pas comme ça
[Musique]
j'avais même pas envie de pisser moi
j'ai vu carte et c'est bon t'es content
de toi non plus tu as vu partout les
ficelles travaux ne bouge se signala et
allez ça s'appelle reviens y a pas
quelqu'un qui veut nettoyer par hasard
évidemment regarder les graisses au
cluster de merde
[Musique]